well hell aren't you looking glamorous
oh my God I can breathe yes those stairs
right every year
oh my gosh let's see if fans just for
you love nice all of this for you oh my
God does it feel being the first guest
to the party it's intimidating being the
first one but I'm hosting for Vogue
today so I had to get here first and get
situated so I'm honored that I'm here
first but it's definitely intimidating
we're hosting for Vogue tonight how much
does Anna weigh in on your look for an
evening like a lot oh really give me the
date yes he um approved the sketch and
was very involved and I will always take
any fashion advice from Anna Wintour
literally whatever she says is what I do
and I'm really happy with this is Sergio
Hudson it was important to me to wear a
black designer so I'm really happy with
how everything came up and I love your
nods to Chanel which is what You Know
Carl was obviously a legendary designer
from what ways have you paid tribute to
Carlos you know with the golden white
the jewelry the chains and I want to do
the 90s inspo hair with the headband
like I was wanting to bring the headband
back I thought that would be really cool
the glasses obviously so yeah finally
how are you going to make it a party
night with your girls after you wrap
your work yeah we gotta hope and trust
me we gotta we gotta we got an after
party plan for sure all right thank you
[Music]